lần đầu thử miếng dán hạ nhiệt Cho cơ thể
cái này là nội địa Trung hay SAO á
mọi người thấy toàn tiếng Trung không à
5.000 Cho một túi này
trong một túi thì sẽ có 2 miếng
tính Ra là 2.000 rưỡi một miếng
nó treo treo kiểu gì á
SAO giống mấy miếng dán hạ sốt quá ta
cái này thì Trinh thấy không có một cái hướng dẫn quá là cụ
thể đâu mọi người muốn dán ở đâu thì dán thôi à
mặt tui có make up chứ hông
tui dán lên trán Cho mọi người coi luôn rồi dán thử lên Tay
a a a
nó mát mọi người
nhưng mà cái sự mát của nó tan đi rất là nhanh
phải phải phải như vậy nè thì mới thấy nó mát
giống như gió luồn qua á
nhưng mà cái miếng này nó lỏng lẻo nha
lắc lắc lắc lắc như này là thấy muốn rớt rồi nè
thấy hông mọi người cái keo này nó hông có dính
tháo Ra một phát
là cảm giác hông có còn một miếng
tinh chất nào ở trên da của mình
hết dán nách thử
nó rát quá
ôi mọi người thấy hông
nói Chung là cũng vui đó
nhưng mà Trinh thấy nó hơi vô dụng nha
tại vì mát cục bộ không à
cảm thấy chỉ có những cái vùng đó nó mát nó the
nó bạc hà lên thôi chứ cơ
thể của mình hông thấy hạ nhiệt đi là mấy
hông mua lại đâu BA trên 10